hey 42 here there are many similarities
between ourselves and our
chimpanzee cousins not only is our dna
almost 99 identical we also
share the same arrangement of bones
muscles
nerves and internal organs we even have
the same brain structure
meaning that much like us they're
capable of experiencing
a whole range of complex thoughts and
emotions
which enable them to partake in an array
of recognizable social interactions
they play together kiss one another
laugh at each other
and even hold hands you can think of
chimpanzees as our
peace hippie cousins a version of
humanity as it might have been
in a more innocent time before we
managed to get ourselves all
corrupted by money power drugs
and intravenous netflix you could think
of chimpanzees that way
but you probably shouldn't because it
turns out
those hairy buggers share plenty of our
darker traits too
don't believe me well let me take you
back to january 1974
when for the first time in documented
history
a species other than our own declared
war
the gumby national park is 13 and a half
square miles
of rainforest enveloped within steep
valleys
grasslands and vegetation providing
the perfect habitat for a wealth of
animal species
the reserve is only accessible by boat
leaving its flora and fauna
free to thrive away from any modern
world interference
making it ideal for observing
chimpanzees
in their natural environment we know
about the war that took place there in
the 70s
thanks to legendary chimpanzee expert
jane goodall
she arrived at gumby in 1960 at the head
of a team of scientists planning to
study the reserve's chimpanzees and she
brought with her
a completely unique approach to
chimpanzee research
instead of attempting to study her
subject's star trek style
at a distance and with the minimum
disturbance possible
goodall took almost exactly the opposite
approach
she set up a feeding station designed to
help the chimps familiarize themselves
with their human observers then got up
as close and personal
as her furry friends would allow it was
a controversial way of doing things
but it gave the team a completely new
perspective on the animals they were
studying
and what they found was remarkable
each chimp had its own unique
personality
that might not sound all that surprising
but at the time
it was groundbreaking it was clear to
goodall that these weren't simply
animals they were individuals
accordingly she gave each of the chimps
a name
eschewing the standard numbering system
usually used during scientific studies
by becoming a part of the chimps
environment and not simply
observers of it goodall and her team
were able to make some startling
discoveries
the first of which is that chimpanzees
are not
as had long been fought vegetarian
in fact their capable hunters and the
research team
observed them stalking wild pigs and
taking down smaller colorbus monkeys
as well as feasting on a wide variety of
insects
if the revelation that chimps were
partial to a nice rare steak
was surprising what good old discovered
next quite literally shook our
understanding
of what it meant to be human in the
jungles of the gumby national park
jane goodall witnessed a chimpanzee
stripping the leaves from a twig
and using it to prize termites from a
mound
again knowing what we know today that
probably doesn't sound all that
impressive
but at the time it was genuinely
earth-shattering
for the first time in the history of
science
we had seen a creature other than a
human being
fashioning and using a tool it's hard to
imagine
just how exciting that must have been it
was just that
nobody had ever seen anything like it
before
at the time tool making was considered
one of the things that
truly set us apart from the rest of the
animal kingdom
an integral part of what it meant to be
human
when godor reported her findings to
louis leakey
her mentor and an expert in the field of
human origins
his reply showed exactly how monumental
the discovery was now we must redefine
man redefine tools or
accept chimpanzees as humans accepting
chimpanzees as humans
might be a bit of a stretch but leaky
statement illustrates
the huge impact godol's discovery had on
our understanding of animal intelligence
and the revelations didn't stop there
because
the dense jungles of the gumby national
park
would soon bear witness to one of the
most astounding events observed
in the animal kingdom on the 7th of
january
1974 a full-scale
war broke out like many human wars
the gumby chimpanzee war was a fight
for succession it started when leaky
leader of the casa keller
a local group of chimps passed away
opening up a power vacuum oh and in case
you're wondering
the leaky in question here wasn't the
previously mentioned paleoanthropologist
louis leaky but a chimpanzee that had
been named after him
leaky had been a strong and popular
alpha male
and had retained his position of power
for many years
during this time he'd overseen a long
period of harmony
within the casa keller community after
his death the most
obvious replacement was an intimidating
male
who went by the not-so-intimidating name
of humphrey but humphrey's leadership
skills
weren't anywhere near the standard set
by his predecessor
and almost immediately he struggled to
establish his authority
over the other chimpanzees to be fair to
humphrey being a chimpanzee
alpha male is a tough gig the alpha is
responsible for the well-being of the
whole community
which can include anywhere between 20
and 150 chimpanzees it's a job that
can't be done alone
and so a complex hierarchy of
lieutenants
are drafted in to ease the burden
unfortunately
humphrey didn't have the same support
network that leaky had established
and so straight away there was
disharmony within the group
humphrey's aggressive attitude was
making him increasingly unpopular with
the rest of his troop
and some of the other chimps seem to be
losing faith in his leadership
the second and third ranking males
brothers
charlie and hugh decided they'd had
enough and fancied their chances at
running things their own way
the brothers were a formidable force and
an obvious threat to humphreys
leadership
tensions continued to rise with
standoffs
and aggressive displays happening more
and more frequently
individually the brothers were no match
for humphrey
but in a tag team match they had a clear
edge
but just when it seemed a royal rumble
in the jungle was inevitable
the chimps appeared to solve things at
the negotiating table
with charlie and hugh unwilling to
accept humphrey's rule
the troops split into two with the
brothers founding a new troop
that was dubbed the kahama community it
isn't unusual for chimp communities to
split up like this
but usually proceedings are fairly
amicable
not so in this case because it soon
became clear that
humphrey had no intention of forgiving
his would-be usurpers
and like a power mad dictator
he began to plan for war summoning five
of his strongest adult males
humphrey led a raiding party into the
territory now occupied by the kahama
chimps
when they came across godi one of the
casa keller males
foraging for food on his own they
ambushed him
godi was brutally attacked by the
raiding party beaten
and torn with hands teeth and even rocks
when goadie had finally stopped
twitching
the casa keller chimps were witnessed
celebrating the kill
whooping loudly and shaking nearby trees
the gumby chimpanzee war had claimed its
first
victim as far as wars go this one was
particularly one-sided humphrey's casa
keller chimps were the aggressors
throughout launching intermittent raids
on the kahama chimps territory
over the course of four years whenever
they came across an
isolated enemy they attacked
goodall's accounts from this period are
genuinely disturbing
she talks of chimps drinking the blood
of their fallen enemies
of cannibalism and of one-time friends
brutally attacking and murdering one
another
neither of these troops were all that
large to begin with and as the kahama
chimps numbers
began to fall it wasn't long before
only one male remained a chimp by the
name of sniff
we can only assume goodall would have
chosen more dangerous sounding names
if she'd known her peaceful chimps would
eventually go
full-on rambo on her anyway sniff
managed to stick it out for a year
before he too was tracked down and
eliminated by humphrey
and his lieutenants with all the males
neutralized the females of the kahama
troop
were largely defenseless one was killed
by the casakela males
two simply disappeared and three were
kidnapped
and taken back to casa keller territory
after four brutal years
the gumby chimpanzee war was over
when goodall reported her findings many
were skeptical of her accounts
believing she was projecting human
characteristics onto the behavior of
chimpanzees
after all animals of almost every
species are known to fight one another
from time to time
usually over territory the opportunity
to reproduce
or access to food and other resources
even we humans are partial to a spot of
fisticuffs
usually because someone got a little too
drunk but
the gumby chimpanzee war was different
these weren't isolated flash points that
sparked when two troops happened to
cross one another's path
accidentally the actions of humphrey and
his chimps
were clearly premeditated over the
course of four years they systematically
eliminated
the males of a neighboring troop in the
most brutal way
imaginable some scientists claimed
godel's
controversial research methods were
behind the war
that somehow by inserting herself into
the mists of the chimps
she'd upset some unseen balance
but subsequent less intrusive studies
would eventually confirm what godall had
always believed
that chimpanzees left alone in their
natural habitat
are capable of premeditated violence
and even warlike conflict
because humans and chimpanzees evolved
from the same species around 6 million
years ago
some anthropologists have suggested the
events of the gumby offer us a glimpse
into the behaviors of our own primitive
ancestors
some even go far as to suggest that such
violent tendencies amongst chimpanzees
have worrying implications for our own
species
namely that we are just innately
predisposed to war
just as chimpanzees seem to be whilst
anyone who watches the news probably
won't find such a concept
all that difficult to believe that
doesn't mean it's true
and another ape species that is equally
closely related to humans
the bonobo seems to display almost no
instinct for war whatsoever in fact they
really are our hippie cousins
they frequently have sex with one
another as a way of saying hello
as you can probably imagine jane goodall
was deeply affected by the events of the
gumby chimpanzee war
and she struggled to shake the memories
of some of the more
horrific things she'd witnessed for many
years after the event
but the study did little to diminish her
fondness for the chimpanzees
and she will continue to study them for
much of her life
her groundbreaking research would
forever alter our understanding of
chimpanzee societies
and in particular how much they mirror
our own
the gumby chimps are still studied to
this day thanks to the gumby stream
research center
which continues to work good all began
almost 60 years ago
it is the longest running field study of
an animal species
ever conducted the gumby chimpanzee war
remains the only event of its kind
documented
at the gumby national park but the casa
keller continue to thrive there
living peacefully alongside other
chimpanzee communities
thankfully any evidence of them planning
a planet of the ape-style global
takeover
is yet to be observed today territorial
violence and hostile infighting
are the least of the chimpanzees worries
poaching
deforestation and human transmitted
diseases
have all contributed to a vast decline
in wild chimpanzee populations
jane goodall continues to work
tirelessly
raising awareness of the plight of
chimpanzees and other endangered species
ensuring that animals such as the ones
in gumby national park
can continue to thrive in a world
without fear of intrusion
from the modern world thanks for
watching
check out my new podcast random
interesting facts
available on youtube spotify apple
podcast
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
link in the description below
thanks